that's
that's why we're alive because when we
are living we feel and when we feel it
it actually
has some type of meaning so let's for
example say something very mundane do
you remember what you ate this breakfast
for breakfast this morning
maybe not because it was just a regular
day
do you remember let's say like it was
your graduation day
do you remember what you had for
breakfast
maybe you didn't even need because
you're so you were so you you're so
nervous you're going on stage you're
gonna get your you know so so emotions
is what makes
things stick
you're not going to remember something
if it wasn't something exciting we don't
have the brain capacity to remember
everything so our brains are made
to process and really
hone in on things that they think is
important so
whether that is extreme happiness
extreme bliss extreme ecstasy to the
other extreme of hurt rejection pain
trauma those are the things that we are
going to always remember so it doesn't
matter if maybe this girl actually had
100 really good encounters with guys but
she doesn't value them because maybe
she's numb to it and then all it takes
is that one time because maybe she's so
traumatized at one point of her life and
so when she does come across someone who
validates her
her um
her perception which is that men are bad
then she just latches on and then she
gets very angry why don't men do the
same thing they do the same
it's not a gender it's not a gender
thing because
men and women
men and women are different in the sense
that women are a lot more volatile and a
lot more outside when it comes to
expressing their emotions the problem
with men is that you do feel and i
actually think that men feel more but
the problem is about feeling i'm talking
about men like women demonizing men
versus men demonizing women i'm just
curious do you guys feel like men and
women do it the same just going around
yes or no no no definitely not what
about you no what about you ash
what
sorry
um what was the question do you think
men and women didn't demonize each other
the same no no can i actually say what i
actually think maybe why women i don't
know about the men but i think this is
why women are so
well why the feminists are so angry okay
um so
i'm gonna say feminine energy because i
believe that we all have a little bit of
both and that's that's actually a good
thing to have we have both in us and
depending on the right situation you
will lean into one more than the other
i think you see it more in a girl
because i i guess we're more encouraged
to be more masculine these days anyways
now
i think when girls innately are female
feminine energy they do want to feel
cherished they want to be taken care of
that is like the most pure basic
feeling to start with right now what
unfortunately happens is that
when girls start maturing so when they
start getting into teenage years
when they start getting awareness of you
know sexuality in themselves they also
unfortunately girls tend to mature
quicker than guys so they outperform
them sometimes at school they're more
quicker at focusing and honing into
growing up and being a little bit more
adulty whereas guys might take a little
bit longer and it just it is just what
it is guys just takes a little bit
longer and that's okay i think i agree
just to cut you off i think i agree with
majora what you're saying but i think
the point that seems to get uh missed
out these days is that
you're
you have more feminine energy and that's
because you're born that way we have
more masculine energy because we're born
away i think society now the problem
society we're trying to make each other
so similar even though we're much
similar and we're different we need to
appreciate the differences between us
so i don't think there's any benefits to
a man being feminine even though this is
what females are requesting nowadays i
want my guy to be more in touch with the
feminine side there's actually no
benefit to it because as a man
you cry we i mean men cry it's not it's
not it's not like we don't cry but
you cry in front of your girl and see
what happens she's not going to respect
you know i've heard people say it
doesn't matter
because it's true
what women are actually requesting these
days like it's actually it's not going
to benefit them in a relationship you
don't want a weak man as soon as you as
soon as you see that your man is weak
you're going to go elsewhere so yeah i
mean i agree and and and i i will that's
a very valid point i agree with you as
well and i get where you're coming from
i think just to finish off my point
so
what from what i said earlier
girls then get pushed if you can see
what i'm saying get pushed to become
very masculine because they feel like
and actually it's from personal
experience my own mother tells me to my
they're pushing us to go to college
they're pushing us to go into very
masculine you know type of trades um and
in order to be i'm in the medical field
so in order to be look if you're coming
to see me do you want me to be a woman
who doesn't know how to make decisions
yeah no you don't want that right real
quick because
it's a very important distinction you
just made then i don't hear much women
say that you just said that your mother
encourages you to be more masculine what
i hear nowadays
is
we as we know on internet it's men
versus women like we don't hear much of
examples of your mother encouraging we
hear men make us like this man because
you've just been honest and saying
mother made me more masculine and
do you think i'm going to say it's true
i think that's a problem
that um
women are making women become more
masculine yeah that's an issue but it's
it's just just before i just got you off
um
that's an important distinction it's not
the men that's doing that because we
want you to be feminine like men want
women to be feminine we don't want you
to be masculine we already got to deal
with the dudes that are masculine we
don't want to deal with a masculine
female so
it's an issue i think
i'm definitely going to agree with you
with that and i'm going to get to the
point you made as well so what happens
is that then the girls are
encouraged to stand up for themselves
don't wait around and rely on the guy
you've got to be self-sufficient by the
way that's a good thing because you
actually if if you're going into a
relationship you want a partnership you
would want so this is how it works so
have you ever seen 300
why would you want a partnership when
that's not how it's worked for all of
history what i meant by partnership i'll
explain a little bit okay
in 300
leonidas is the king and he has his
queen
when
when someone comes to his doorstep and
threatens him literally threatens his
his whole livelihood his people
with literally cutting people's heads
off walking up to him and showing
violence
his queen stepped up and said
this is not okay
and the messenger was turning around and
saying how dare you as a woman
speak
and in the end when leonidas then
before he kicked them down the well
um he actually said you disrespected my
queen and actually what she said as well
is she said like only spartan women can
give birth to spartan men which is
strong men so what is beautiful about
that relationship is that they are not
equal in the sense that they don't have
the same energy but
we can agree that they're both strong in
different ways but that's not a
partnership because he needs okay so
what what i meant is i'm not saying
she's never eating she needs him more
than he needs her so what i'm saying is
i'm not saying that they're equal and
that they give the same thing in but
what they do is that they complement
each other and support each other and
the beautiful thing about that
relationship is that she's actually very
accomplished so he feels safe walking
away and going into war potentially
never coming back
but he knows that his wife is strong so
she can